un nouveau cru s'annonce sur bonnet sur
la côte dans cette circonscription au
coeur viticole du sud du département
mais qui s'étend du val de saône aux
portes du morvan on prépare la nouvelle
cuvée côté député il y aura aussi du
nouveau après quatre mandats alain
suguenot touché par le cumul des mandats
a choisi la mairie c'est son suppléant
hubert poullot au maire de saint
philibert qui monte en première ligne
les deux hommes inverse leur rôle dans
une sorte de continuité
on a décidé en commun de rester ensemble
mais d'inverser effectivement notre
représentativité où vous l'avez compris
alain suguenot continuera de siéger dans
sa mairie de bol et moi je viendrai
c'est effectivement à l'assemblée
nationale
sur le terrain il y aura pas de
changement on continuera à entendre
comme on l'a fait depuis des années à
être à l'écouté de nos compatriotes de
nos élus et puis bien sûr de l'ensemble
du monde économique dans cette
circonscription emmanuel macron est
arrivé qu'en troisième position au
premier tour de l'élection
pas de quoi arrêter ces marcheurs qui
ont choisi didier parisse comme candidat
en tient sous préfet de beaune et aussi
longtemps directeur de cabinet de
françois patriat l'un des premiers
soutiens du président ont déjà d'être
moins connu c'est le sens de la volonté
du président de la république faire que
nous ayons un renouvellement de la vie
politique je n'ai jamais été élu c'est
un fait
pour autant je crois bien connaître ce
territoire de par mes anciennes
fonctions et et de parfaite que j'habite
depuis vingt ans la circonscription du
côté du front national on a de grandes
ambitions après l'envolée des dernières
départementale marine le pen a confirmé
dans plusieurs cantons
de quoi conforter rené lioret directeur
commercial et depuis 30 ans au fn on a
un vote front national qui est très fort
dans les zones rurales aux dernières
élections dans la circonscription le
front national est arrivé globalement en
tête au premier tour et a totalisé près
42 % des voix au deuxième tour avec des
cantons comme braz et qu'ils ont
fait 20 points de plus que la moyenne
nationale ou arnel du guip en plus
enfin alors que benoît hamon a fait
moins de 5% dans ce secteur le ps qui
avait poussé alain suguenot au deuxième
tour investi le maire de nolay
reste que ce bastion de la droite depuis
15 ans apparaît cette fois plus menacée
par l'émergence d' en marche et la
montée des extrêmes et je vous laisse
découvrir les noms des autres candidats
en lice ils sont en effet dix au total
dans cette circonscription a brigué les
suffrages des électeurs le 11 juin
prochain